welcome and thank you uh for those who
have joined my talk
my name is rabini bhomik i'm a staff
scientist at
roche tissue diagnostic located in
tucson arizona
i develop multiplex assay for tissue and
new sample types like 3d spheroids
using roche ihc ish automated staining
platform and proprietary dye
today i will discuss fluorescent
multiplexing of 3d spheroid ffbe
using discovery ultra automated
straining instrument
and reagent in this talk
i will discuss the entire fluorescent
multiplex assay workflow using 3d
spheroids
and aggregate ffp section as model
system
the target is to stain four biomarkers
on the same 3d ffbe section
first we identify the biomarker panel
and choose the protocols
for multiplex staining in our discovery
automated
ultra ihc instrument i will discuss some
of the key parameters needed
to optimize multiplex if stain
using roche proprietary detection kit
once we stay in the multiplex slide we
have to consider what
imaging instruments we want to use are
we going to do
a hole slide imaging or multispectral
imaging
for successful imaging with roche
proprietary fluorescent dye
i will discuss what key changes are
needed in the scanner hardware and
software
finally i will give some examples of
downstream analysis to complete the
workflow
for those who are less familiar with the
discovery ultra
instrument this is an automated staining
platform for ru
acid development it's a high throughput
auto stain
that can stain up to 30 slides the
instrument gives reproducible stain
minimizes human error and saves time in
the top carousel there are 35
dispenser holder though in the multiplex
chain
some of the dispensers involve
detection kits inhibitor secondary
antibody
blocker counter stain dappy for a
complete five place
plex stain you need up to 19 dispensers
the next carousel consists of 30 slide
drawers
each slide has an individual reaction
chamber and
heating pad underneath the slide the
heating pad plays an important role for
the success of five
plex assay there is a bulk container
holding
a three to seven liter fluid consisting
of
liquid coverslip wash buffer and cc1
cc2 etc finally there are two buckets um
that holds the waste at the bottom of
the instrument
the instrument comes with two proto
procedures
one is an ru discovery universal
which is an open procedure with numerous
options and you can build your
own assay but around 2016 we
actually came up with you discovery five
plex if procedure
which is semi-locked and easy to use
and can generate five plex plus dappy
stain in 10 to 12 hours
we also provide numerous training and
white paper describing
in details how to build and five plex
assay i will also discuss the filter
setting needed in
imaging scanner use when using roche
detection chemistry
so here i will briefly uh discuss the
unique uh detection chemistry of
roche dye we are trying to do
fluorescent multiplexing ihc assay
we are using four roche proprietary
fluorophore
and dappy as counter stain each floor
comes as separate
detection kit and each detection kit
consists of tsa fluorophore
and a compatible h2o2 dispenser
the slides are stained by tsa
amplification method which i will
describe now
let us have for example we have a tissue
with an antigen of interest
we first apply primary antibody to seek
the antigen followed by secondary
antibody specific
to the primary antibody here the
secondary antibody
is not conjugated with a fluorescent dye
but it is conjugated with an
hrp enzyme the final
detection readout we use a rose
detection kit
the tsa fluorophore in the detection kit
comes
as comes in an inactive state
when the staining protocol is starts it
dispenses
the tsa fluorophore and hydrogen
peroxide
on the tissue this reacts with the hrp
enzyme
and converts to a highly reactive state
that covalently
covalently binds to the tyrosine residue
around the antigen
the excess and unbound antigen reacts
with the reaction buffer
and the washing steps um inbuilt in the
protocol
removes all the unbound unnecessary
fluorophore
the staining is highly specific here is
an example of ki 67
stained on tonsil using discovery
dcc kit
so we are looking here is an animated
cartoon
of serial multiplex if
using dyramide amplification
the schema shows five antigen that we
want to
stain the first antigen is detected um
and the fluorophore is deposited as we
described before
this is followed by heat deactivation
the heat deactivation step is extremely
important
because it deactivates the primary
secondary complex
the following washing steps actually
removes the primary secondary complex
and
unbound fluorophore leaving behind only
the fluorescent dye
around the antigen of interest
the next step we target the second
biomarker
and we deposit dcc followed by heat
deactivation
the process continues and we deposit red
610
cy5 and fam
on which deposits around
biomarker three four five finally
in the last step we do counterstain
dappy
the fluorescent sequence um
is locked in this procedure for ease of
use
so now that we understand how the
instrument and the assay works
let us understand the aci strategy for
the 3d spheroid sections the samples
that we
selected were chosen from two most
widely studied cancer indication
nsclc and crc the biomarkers
panel chosen for nsclc are um egfr ttf1
uh alc and ck7 whereas for crc we chose
msh2 msh6
braf and ck 20.
we i also went ahead and chose the
my antigen the antibody
fluorophore pairing there are a lot of
optimization that has to be done
but this is a start finally we also have
to look at the
staining pattern of each biomarker
for that we run chromogenic stain with
an on market product
and look at the staining pattern and
and expression in the nuclear membrane
and cytoplasm
we upload the samples on discovery ultra
and choose the reo5 plex
protocol and also um
load the recommended antibody and
dispensers um to initiate the run
the protocol automatically conducts um
deeper antigen retrieval and cell
conditioning
followed by four sequential stain with
three heat deactivation uh in between
once the process is complete we get four
plex slide
at the end of the process
so why are we using 3d spheroids and
aggregates as a model c
system recently we see a shift
from using 2d to 3d
2d monolayers by now we know are flat
rigid
and grows on synthetic surface there is
an absence of cell address
extracellular matrix interaction and
cell cell interaction
and they have poor performance on
preclinical drug sensitivity study
and shows high failure rate the industry
is moving towards 3d spheroids
aggregates
organize asymploids and because they
mimic solid tumor
with spatial configuration has
heterogeneity shows
gene expression they have long term
growth and sometimes you can do extended
time course studies they have superior
performance with drug efficacy
sensitivity and resistance
and more recently organized are
developed from
patient-derived solid tumors for
pre-clinical
drug studies
so in this multiplexing the key
components are
we took four biomarkers for nsclc
spheroids
um the alk um
identified with cy5 egfr with rhodamine
6g
ttf1 with red 610 and ck7 with fam
for crc the b raf was identified with
rhodamine 6g chloroform msh2 with
dcc msh6 with fam and ck20 with
red 610 we use the same antibodies and
dispensers for chromogenic
and multi multiplex fluorescent
uh assay we optimized the nsclc and crc
on ffbe tissues first and then
we replicated the same parameters on 3d
ffpe
sections the cell lines there that were
used
for nsclc are h2228
and h1975 for crc the cell lines are
ht29
and km12 finally we did image
quantitation like
uh signal intensity cell number and
co-localization
the key optimization parameters involve
antibody fluorophore pairing primary
antibody concentration
primary antibody incubation time and
also
morphology and staining concordance
of fluorescent multiplex slide with
chromogenic single
staining on the imaging side we had to
consider
how to limit auto fluorescence low br
bleed through between adjacent channel
robust dappy signal for optimal stain
recognition and segmentation because the
optimum segmentation will help
downstream analysis
the workflow stream starts with
um in our in nsclc and crc ffp
tissue where we optimized antibody
fluorophore
pairing the fluoresce for fluorescent
stain optimization epitope study and
staining concordance
and then we transferred the protocol
and tested it on nsclc and crc 3d
spheroid aggregates
followed by checking the concordance of
the staining
and finally doing multi-spectral imaging
and image analysis
using a vector 3 platform from akoya
biosciences
here is an example of chromogenic
singleplex stain on colorectal tissue
you can see nuclear stain of msh2 and
msh6
cytoplasmic stain of ck 20
and diffuse membrane and cytoplasmic
stain
brav b600e
we tested each biomarker
on 3d ffbe here is an example of ck7
alk egfr and ttf1
on h2228 spheroids
and ck20 msh2 brav v600e and msh6
on hd29 spheroids
for antibody selection and stain
optimization
several steps has to be considered for
multiplexing stain
we have to play various optimization
parameters
for example we look at antibody
incubation time
we try to test the antibodies that are
already available in the dispenser
we start with single plex dab stain and
check for the staining pattern
the optimum staining can be increased or
decreased
for example you can see in alk we have
increased from 16 minutes to 20 minutes
for ck 7 we decreased it to eight
minutes
another option is antibody titration
study
if the dab stain is too dark we have to
dilute the antibody
till we get an optimum signal intensity
and staining pattern
and then we can use that dilution to do
a fluorescent multiplexing which is much
more sensitive
epitope study and fluorophore pairing is
another
important parameter heat deactivation
plays a very important role
in in multiplexing success um
the heat deactivation um is not only
removes the primary secondary complex it
actually
acts as a mini antigen retrieval
so here in the schema you can see the
biomarker in position 1 does not get any
heat deactivation
whereas biomarker in position 5 gets 4
heat deactivation
so an epitope may be destroyed with
multiple heat deactivation or it may
open up
and give give better staining pattern
um based on where the epitope
is positioned so we recommend
that you test each biomarker in
different positions
and check for its um
stability with heat deactivation and
check for the morphology staining
pattern and staining intensity
for tsa amplification how long you
deposit
the tsa floor actually gives you the
signal intensity
and we recommend using 8 to 12 minutes
in the protocol here is the sequential
multiplexing of nsclc tissue
here you can see ck7 cytoplasmic stain
ttf1 nuclear stain you can see pdf
pdl1 membrane strain and then diffused
um
egfr stain and finally there is the
merged image of nsclc tissue
um here is a sequential multiplex stain
of
crc tissue showing a ck20 stain
very low b raf v600e and
nuclear stain of msh2 and msh6
for and finally the merged image
once we completed the fluorescent
multiplexing the each biomarker
were tested with chromogenic
multiplex slide for concordance study
and and so you can see the chromogenic
uniflex and fluorescent multiplex
chaining concordance of
alk egfr ttf1
and ck7 in h2228 3d spheroids
similarly we also checked for
concordance with b draft v600e
msh2 nuclear stain msh6 nuclear stain
and ck7
in ht29 3d spheroid
finally here is a merged image of h2228
3d spheroid consisting of four biomarker
and dappy and here is
an hd29 3d spheroid
multiplexer merged image consisting of
msh2 msh6
uh ck20 and br600e
now that we have completed multiplex
stain um
i will discuss some of the
characteristics of
roche fluorescent dyes most of the rose
fluorescent dyes
are tuned to have
narrow spectral bandwidth that helps
minimizing
a signal overlap
[Music]
across multiple channels except for dcc
and dappy in addition we also recommend
using narrowband
filter compatible to this die so that it
separates the discrete six colors within
the visible and ir
spectrum the
filter-based imaging systems like zeiss
olympus hamamatsu we recommend using the
compatible filter set as shown in the
table
the chroma um actually provides these
specialized filter sets um
like aqua fish goldfish redfish
pam etc
as the filters are chosen
so that we get this discrete signal of
one biomarker per
imaging channel
we used spectra three from aqua
biosciences
here also the whole slide imaging
utilizes
filter-based imaging so in order to
accommodate uh
roche fluorophore and in an aquaria
vector 3 system we recommend
taking out one of the filter cubes say
texas red
and incorporate acquire filter cube from
chroma
um a step-by-step configuration
of vector 3 and inform
for roche dies are available
in aqua website
since we are using
roche proprietary fluorophore we have to
build spectral library
for that we performed singleplex if with
each floor four
and also we generated a slide with
dappy um ki 67 tonsil
slides were prepared and uh the
spectra were captured for each
fluorophore using
a manufacturer's recommendation and then
we saved the
spectral library and used it for
downstream
uh analysis using inform 2.4
the imaging um helps
in autofluorescence removal we get
cleaner image which removes
signal bleed through from adjacent
channel
for multi-spectral imaging actually in
vector 3
um the spectral camera takes images
from 420 to 720. here each column
represents a different filter cubes
typically a fluorescent dye shows um
blends through different filter cubes
for example you can see
um dappy as has enveloped into
um dcc filters cube
and here red 610 actually has
is showing bleed through in rhodamine 6g
as well as
psi 5 filter q so with the help of
inform the spectral library the inform
platform
actually is able to
segregate and assign the signals to the
right
filters the autofluorescence which goes
across multiple
channel are also segregated and
separated
in the final image
so here is an old slide scan and taken
in 10x
and we do multi-spectral imaging of the
field of view
um identified at 20x
so here's an example of h2228 image
of ck7 stained with fam
the same field of view
shows egfr stained with rhodamine 60
followed by nuclear stain ttf1 with
red 610 and diffused alk stained with
sci-fi
finally you get the merged image of
h2228
i'm going to talk about co-registration
of msh2 and msh6 in the ht29 sample
here is the dappy stain of ht-29
you see most of the nucleus are stained
with
msh2 and dcc whereas few of them
are stained with msh-6 and fam
finally we get co-localized msh2 msh6
as you see here the segmentation
is another important parameter that is
needed for downstream analysis
in inform the segmentation is very easy
fast and has a live window to see your
segmentation result
we can identify um clearly
all the cells in a tightly in
spheroid section the cell segmentation
is done by
with the help of dappy and a membrane
marker
and this actually helps in downstream
analysis
the other thing that we utilized in
inform is the co-localization mask
here you can see the colorization mask
actually
showed gray cells as double negative
magenta cells as double positive
sciences
as msh2 only and m
single msh6 is represented by the green
cell
the immediate analysis was done
following cell segmentation and the
signal intensity was measured
the adaptive cell segmentation helped us
to demarcate the nuclear membrane and
cytoplasm as
shown in the figure left we did
signal intensity study of two
spheroids h2228 and
1975 representing nsclc
for crc we utilize hd29 and km12
spheroid first what we did
was the cell number was counted a
threshold was
for signal intensity we collected the
signal uh thresh
above the threshold and plotted the
chart
what we saw was the signal intensities
were different for different biomarkers
for example we found um alk expression
in
h2228 and we did not see it in
1975 which is a non-expressive cell line
we also saw that ttf1 was threefold
stronger
than ttf1 in 1975.
so this kind of studies an
intravariability among the cell lines
and spheroids
gives us an idea which spheroids you
want to
utilize for downstream drug study
in crc even though msh2 msh6 brav
showed comparable signal we saw a great
difference in the ck20 expression
in km12 and and ht29
finally we actually use the
co-localization mask
to look at the msh2 msh6
single and dual expression in crc 3d
steroids
here is an example of multiplex if
in the middle panel you see the
segmentation and in the last panel you
see the km12
um you'll see the segmentation mask
of in the km12 3d steroids
in the graph you can we can clearly see
that
msh2 expression was significantly higher
in hd29 compared to km12
even though the co-localization of msh2
and msh6
was higher in km12 versus hd29
so in conclusion we described the
workflow of staining
assay optimization imaging and image
analysis
for fluorescent multiplexing of 3d
spheroid ffb
of nsclc and crc cells we utilize 3d
spheroid because of its similarity
with solid tumor tissue we performed on
discovery um staining instrument using
discovery reagent
the scanning filters um adjusted to
accommodate unique uh discovery
fluorescent dye
multispectral imaging and analysis
were performed in vector 3 and in form
from aqua biosciences
potential use of fluorescent
multiplexing technology in preclinical
drug study using
patient-derived 3d organized organize
could be done in future
here are some of the important
references that might help
we recently published a paper on 3d
spheroid
staining and journal of cellular
biochemistry
there is a guide configured to configure
vector 3
and inform platform for
roche fluorophore in aqua website and
of course we have the white paper that
describes in details how to develop an
essay
we have to acknowledge and a huge group
of people here
who played and significant role in
making this project a success
a gene boyer is an expert in our
institute to build uh
3d spheroids um a lot of
the people here actually helped in
developing a chromogenic stain
identifying
biomarkers sectioning tissues and i
can't thank them enough
for making this project a success
thank you